you have an unusual parenting style well
I mean they call it is your name so
attachment parenting is like the
umbrella term isn't it true the kids
sleep in your bed till all the every
night people do it a lot of different
ways the fact is in the early stages of
parenting and breastfeeding it is normal
for mammals to sleep near their babies
and most adults don't want to sleep
alone so so children also don't want to
sleep alone so there's there's a way
that there's a set of and also because
like this is my Neuroscience you know
perspective as well it's hormonally
benef you know beneficial for Mammal
babies to sleep near their moms in
particular that's not bad my kids have
never negotiated with me bargained with
me to stay up one more glass of water
they don't fear sleep sleep is a safe
place they now sleep together they're
five and a half and eight two little
boys they they don't fear sleep or night
time and like yeah as a kid like I hated
night time I would cry I was up all
night like that's not good either and
when I hear people like oh I can't get
my kid to stay in bed maybe they just
want to know that you're around and be
closer I don't know figure it out
breastfeeding till the kid is
yes and the Leche League International
and organizations that support
breastfeeding I'm also a lactation
educator counselor so I come from also
like a sort of educated lactation
perspective yes breastfeeding is a
normal natural thing that primates do
and they often will do it longer than is
socially acceptable to Western culture I
was not breastfeeding my four-year-old
on the subway when he was two yes there
was a trip from Coney Island where no
one would have had a good Subway trip if
I didn't breastfeed that kid right so
yeah that happened yes I kept him quiet
happy and like everything was fine so
you know part of your parenting the kids
do not wear diapers oh no so my kids did
not wear diapers that's called
elimination communication but it's
actually I know it's actually separate
from attachment parenting many people
some people who do attachment parenting
do this but yeah so you uh basically
babies are born giving signals when they
pee and poop I promise and if you learn
those signals and reinforce them they
will give them stronger and clearer and
I we taught our kids to sign this is the
Sign Language sign for potty by the time
they were 12 months old they were
signing for potty they couldn't walk
talk or eat solids they only breastfed
but they could sign for the potty before
they could even walk talk is it the same
Theory with a dog like dogs will teach
you can teach them to go to the bathroom
outside right so you're more training
yourself to learn the cues that the baby
will give and if you don't reinforce
them a baby will stop giving those cues
and it's not for everyone believe me but
yeah especially with boys it's easy we
just hold them up over a tree and they
would wear cloth diapers but then they
were in underwear by like 17 months
there's no reward and Punishment there's
no gold star there's no chocolate chips
it's literally that they have taught you
what to look for and it's a fascinating
method of communicating with your child
because all they know is that you
understand them and are there to support
them it's not for everyone and it's not
part of attachment parenting but I did
write about it in my book you can tell
yes when your child is going to have to
pee so absolutely if your kid is
sleeping in bed with you did they pee on
the bed anytime pretty well yes but
pretty much every time a baby wakes up
to nurse or gets Restless at night
they're probably going to pee especially
if they're breastfeeding like it just
kind of goes through them so I would
have a potty by the side of the bed wow
and I literally would just listen no
diapers my my little one well I would
use cloth diapers that often were dry
but yeah my little one I did it for
literally from the first week he was
born my older son I'd started at like
six months and and my ex was like this
is crazy he's like you want to really
know his accident he's like you no
there's plenty of accidents but that's
your thing I don't know you deal with it
I have wood floors and you wash things
and you always smell like something with
a baby like a super
involved mother I was and I still am
it's different when they're not it's
impression but how do you have a life of
your own when you're that I mean you
devote every second of your life to your
kids well look in their first years yeah
no no no and in their first years it was
very intense it's very intense and the
fact is especially like in the industry
in the way like why aren't you going for
martinis with your girlfriends why are
you going away for weekends with us and
yeah it's hard but I think what's
amazing and what always existed in human
and and primate culture was a group of
women who supported each other in what
they were doing and took turns doing
things it's fascinating we've lost that
in our communities but that's why people
do things like go to these the Leche
League meetings and go to these like
holistic moms organization meetings
because you meet like-minded people who
won't make you feel crappy that you're
not going for martinis we made it work
in those years we live in a culture
where we're all sort of off on our own
absolutely you're right if you go to a
La Leche no and the goal is to like have
your stomach sucked out and go for
martinis either that wasn't my thing but
you really are very selfless I'm very
impressed with you it's a big soccer
it's a sacrifice I agree it is it's a
sacrifice I mean you know one would
almost say gee why doesn't she go out on
a date or why doesn't she go with the
girls maybe she'll meet her but you're
devoted to these kids well and the fact
is when I'm not with them I get my time
to socialize and to have to learn to
have friendships as an adult because you
know my whole adult life has been like
being married and being with kids but
when I'm with them yeah I want to be
with them and I don't know they're happy
they're rested they have rosy cheeks and
they like being with me and with their
dad they seem pretty well adjusted and
they are very are they in regular
schools now no so we we homeschool which
is again not a celebrity thing but I
mean I'm the only celebrity in our
homeschooling community that I know of
but how can you homeschool them well
because they're with they're with their
dad and they he does or is he just free
home he got his Masters in Poli SCI and
he is their full-time I mean yeah he
takes them to all their classes he
teaches them I mean like this is kind of
the life and again that's not a
celebrity elitist we're hiring tutors in
our house like the only tutor we have is
for Jewish studies for my older son
right but no they go to classes in the
park there's Lego engineering classes
there's all sorts of there's PE all
those things they go to and he takes
them when he's with them I teach them
piano I do a little tap dancing class
for them and another one of their
friends and I will teach them I taught
my older son to read and write Hebrew
and as they get older I'll probably be
their science teacher you are a
throwback to a day that I mean doesn't
exist anymore you should almost be in a
museum I am in the wrong era correct you
really are you you should be Amish or
something like this yes or you should be
on a kibbutz right there we go no I'm
very kabutsy this is very kabutz live
absolutely no I believe in that sort of
communal uh communal participation
foreign